service and brought to you today by your
television provider
journalist and author cameron mcwhirter
and historian sage matthew discuss
what's known as the red summer of 1919 a
months-long period of racial unrest and
violence against african americans
including world war one veterans in
multiple cities and states the national
world war one museum and memorial
national archives at kansas city and
greater kansas city black history study
group co-hosted this event the national
world war one museum provided the video
and this evening we're pleased to have
two distinguished speakers scholars with
us
in dialogue about the red summer of 1919
and
we'll have a discussion between our
guests followed by a brief
q a should there be time for us to do
that
and i'm so pleased tonight to introduce
two of our friends and colleagues the
first being dr sage matthau
dr matthau is an associate professor of
history at the university of minnesota
she's currently or just finishing up a
faculty fellowship at harvard
university's warren center for studies
in american history she earned a joint
phd in history and african-american
studies from yale university and
specialises in 20th century american and
african-american history
with an emphasis on immigration war race
globalization social movements and
political resistance
and she's the author of
a number of books one of which is
available outside and i'd encourage you
to grab a copy while you can but an
upcoming book as well the glory of their
deeds a global history of black soldiers
and the great war era and sage was
working on that book if i recall as part
of your uh work at um
at the warren center are we close to
publication
she started when she was five so it's
almost done
so
really sage is a great friend
of ours and
we're just so delighted to have you back
here with us again thank you so please
join me in welcoming dr matthau
and joining us tonight is a scholar who
also has a specialized focused on the
red summer of 1919
and the fight of this nation to cross to
create a just and equitable society
cameron mcwhirter is a staff reporter
for the wall street journal based in
atlanta he covers politics economics
breaking news and other subjects and
he's worked in a variety of countries
reporting from bosnia iraq costa rica
and other places and for our purposes
most significantly
he is the author of a compelling text
red summer the summer of 1919 and the
awakening of black america
so please join me in welcoming cameron
i want to read to you just a portion
from
cameron mcmurdo's book
so if you would just listen this really
frames i think our conversation this
evening
just reminds us to silence your devices
so thank you
so a reading from cameron's book
on june 26 1919 as many as one as ten
thousand whites gathered in the field
just outside ellisville mississippi to
watch a bound exhausted and wounded
black man named john hatfield
as he was hoisted up the branch of a
giant sweet gum tree
vendors sold flags trinkets and souvenir
photographs
local politicians delivered speeches
young boys crowded in the tree to look
down at the wild-eyed screaming
it was a country fair
political rally
and public murder
rolled into one
after world war one black americans
fervently hoped for a new epoch of peace
prosperity and equality
but this civil rights movement was not
to be
instead the euphoria of victory
evaporated to be replaced by the worst
spate of anti-black violence
labeled the red summer the riots and
lynchings would last from april to
november 1919
claiming hundreds of lives
blacks responded by fighting back with
an intensity and determination never
seen before introducing the first
stirrings
of the civil rights movement
that would change america forever
friends please welcome our guests this
evening
cameron mcwhirter and sage massa
[Applause]
well i'd like to begin by thanking you
for being here on such a lovely evening
um as cameron
no doubt uh recalls we are almost to the
day
at the centenary of uh
the worst of the riots i'd say
but the riots had begun at least on the
in the united states
for
at least a couple of months
there were a cup there are a couple of
things that are reminiscent of that
summer
uh for me it's always the weather it was
an incredibly hot weather summer
and one of the things that we historians
know is that when there is a spike
in the weather in the heat
we start smacking each other around
and it's no surprise that most of these
race riots occur during heat waves
can you well i just came here from
chicago uh where we
uh me and many other people were marking
the centennial of the chicago riot which
was
certainly the worst urban riot in the
united states that year
and it started because of the heat
literally because of the heat
people there was no air conditioning at
that time and
five young teenage teenage
african-american
men
snuck through the white neighborhoods of
chicago to get to the south side beach
and they went swimming
and they
swam in an area that was sort of near
the
de facto black beach and the de facto
white beach it was not there wasn't
legal segregation in chicago but their
raft that they were on they weren't very
good swimmers drifted into the white
beach and that was
in this incredibly tense period that's
all that was needed to spark a massive
race rat
well that's a wonderful place to start
actually um and that is because one of
the things that our i argue about this
era writ large so not just 1919 but the
1910s and the 1920s and truthfully well
throughout the 20th century what we see
in this instance of these kids we can't
ever forget that they're children
playing outdoors
is that we are reminded that the very
idea of leisure is contested the very
idea of belonging is contested right so
these children do not belong on that
beach because free time is itself
segregated as is the very space where
that free time should be spent so it's
not just beaches right that are uh
segregated whether it's officially or by
de facto uh practice
but so too sometimes are parks
golf courses um swimming pool public
swimming pools and so in these
these these social spaces become
just as charged as the workplace
neighborhoods in terms of contested
terrains when it comes to belonging for
african americans especially in urban
spaces well then i would go farther and
say that the smallest
when the situation was so charged the
smallest incident
would lead to tremendous violence and
rumor and gossip played a huge role in
all this in the washington riot which
occurs earlier in july of 1919 it occurs
when a uh
there were there was a whole frenzy of
panic produced by the media
unfortunately
of um
the belief that uh african-american men
were attacking white women
and
a white woman we don't know exactly what
happened but a white woman was walking
down the street and was jostled by two
african men african-american men walking
the other way that's
we know that happened right but that
became
did you hear about two absolutely men
raping a white woman and that leads to
mayhem so in 1921 just a couple of years
later in the worst of all race riots in
american history the tulsa race riot of
1921 um it all begins with people
bumping into each other in an elevator
right so these small
spaces where again
the complicated relationship across race
racial lines and across gender lines
become aggravated or amplified um of
course 1919 also reminds us that
violence
moves on rumor
violence moves on rumor so it is so
often the case that we hear that this
happened that that didn't happen and
before you know it no one even remembers
why
we're fighting in the first place so
kind of like a middle school brawl
right
and as a reporter today i can't tell you
how
how constant a problem that remains in
terms of trying to deal with whether
something's true was that something
actually happened it's a constant uh
it's a constant
paranoia fear of of journalists we go to
sleep agonizing over that all the time
so let's take a step back and for for
people who might not
uh remember or or know
what conditions were like at the end of
the summer of 1919 or rather at the end
of spring of 1919. that's a great yeah
so we have
american soldiers starting to come back
sometimes 100 000 a month right
disgorging from great ships in on on
american on coastal in coastal port
cities
they are concerned about a return to
normalcy whatever that could mean
uh so whether that's a return to their
jobs return to their families return to
their social standing
return to the actual physical place from
whence they came and not everyone wants
to go back right where they went from
once they came um we're talking about
men who are between the ages for the
most part of 18 to 30
not the most stable
part of our
citizenry
right no but it's true
right it's true and then an absolutely
understudied aspect for me and it's part
of what i write about is that we did not
have a language for what today we call
ptsd
that these men had been thrown into the
worst of the fighting the most chaotic
of the fighting in the last six months
of the war even though american soldiers
did not see
the level of destruction that other
european troops had experienced over the
course of all four years nonetheless you
don't have to be in the trenches for
four years to know how destabilizing how
how devastating it is to
witness your friends being
uh
torn to shreds and so we get these guys
arriving right in philly in boston and
new york and newport news and charleston
and it's like thanks for coming out
off you go
and that doesn't even yet include
how african americans felt about this
expectation that after having
crossed the atlantic after having
hurriedly established much of the
infrastructure that made it possible for
the american army to fight in europe
building the camps building the barracks
building the railway lines feeding
people um spending hours loading and
unloading ships only to then be treated
like gum under their under one's shoe by
their own government well that
decommissioning also yeah yeah that
decommissioning
did wasn't as smooth as see you later
sometimes sometimes they had to wait
around correct and that led to you know
young men charleston's a classic example
young men milling around
looking for booze mostly which was
illegal
and you know that riot begins when a
bunch of men give five bucks to a guy
who says he's going to go get him some
illegal liquor and
like a million other hustlers
before and after him he takes off and
never comes back and this the soldiers
riot but i i do think i mean
you're dead on and everything you're
saying i think
it's really important for people if when
i talk to people about 1919
they generally have the impression that
america was
this victorious power and everything was
great and we're about to head into the
jazz age and everything's fantastic in
fact it was a really panicky time for
for the world but certainly for america
we had
people um
the bolsheviks had taken over russia
anarchists were sending bombs to
politicians
there was an a record number of strikes
around the country there was a high cost
of living was was rising so people were
having having trouble paying their bills
people were coming these soldiers were
pouring back into the to the uh the
domestic economy and they couldn't get
the jobs they used to have white and
black right and
um
in that frothy mess
i like to mention there was a political
cartoon at the time
of the globe
sitting in bed just biting his nails and
all these panicky things are flying
around his head like that's influenza
was sweeping the world so it was a
really nerve-wracking time
and in all that
three pretty positive things for
african-americans had happened but
because it happened in this
frothy
chaos
it was they were they were focal points
for for anti-black violence
so soldiers being the most so we also
get you know there's also another
ingredient in this frothy mess that you
described and that is that over the
course of the war i mean it had started
before but it went from trickle to flood
um
that is that african americans cast down
their buckets and headed north
right they followed the rivers and the
railway lines that made it possible for
them to vote with their feet as workers
and so we get an actual departure of
african americans from the south to
northern industrial cities
to replace
um the
the workers who had gone off to war but
that's kind of that's cut off
um but also it's important to know that
this was nonetheless
a
a concrete choice by african americans
to say after almost 50 years of
of farming
uh
with over with control over their wages
that this share cropping system is not
working right it's a perpetual cycle of
poverty we have we cannot in fact own
and hold on to land and so what will i
do what is the very fundamental exercise
of freedom to move
and so one addendum yeah one key
addendum to that is
um
northern industry turned to the south
and it was very advantageous for the
owners of factories to have
african-americans come up to work for
them first of all often their wages were
suppressed secondly they were sort of
inherent union busters because the
unions were very reluctant to let
african americans into the unions at
that time so you had this perfect
situation for the factory owner he could
divide his factory floor weaken the
unions bring in cheaper labor and um
but you're right but generally for
african americans it was a better
situation to get rid of jim to get away
from jim crow
definitely but it adds to this idea that
after the war we have to get those
people back into their place get out of
my neighborhood get out of my workplace
get out of my army get off my streetcar
get off my beach
and so it's a very physical set of
contacts in today's parlance we might
refer to these as microaggressions right
but there's a lot of that and one of the
things that i enjoy doing with my
students is is having them look at
newspapers from the period and you get
all of these accounts
especially in north carolina for some
reason of white women going around
stabbing people with their umbrellas
and the reason they do this and and some
black women are also fighting back and
the reason they do this is because the
sidewalk is a contested space and they
want to reclaim that as their entitled
place and so black people are to walk in
the street with the muck that ran
through the streets and what we see are
african-americans saying i will not be
moved
you mentioned um some black
intellectuals and some other important
advancements organizational advancements
that were happening during the war might
you tell us a little bit more about that
uh well i mean
this title of this talk is we return
fighting and that's w e dubois who was a
great intellectual writing for the
crisis at that time and he
he made he made it clear and loud and
clear that
these soldiers who had just fought for
democracy and were told repeatedly
you're fighting to save democracy we're
going to come back changed and we're
going to come back demanding a different
situation than the one they had entered
they had left and
that i think played a key role in
formulating people's um
views of
what they were expecting when they came
back uh i think the
african-american soldiers encountered uh
i have numerous examples of these little
incidents in my book
one
they came back wearing their uniforms
often because that's all the only
clothing they had
but when they would get back to the
small towns in the south
they would be spit on they would be
yelled at they would be threatened in
some cases they were killed
and these sort of flare-ups were
happening all the time
there was i remember reading i have in
my book there were
lots of letters going back and forth
with in the u.s railroad administration
soldiers would be coming back sleeping
in the in the births of their railroad
cars to go home because they were
decommissioned and as soon as they
crossed the mason-dixon line
white men in the cars would stand up and
say hey
they have to go to the colored car
and other white men there's one instance
where other white men stand up and say
wait a minute these guys just fought for
us in europe and there's a huge argument
that erupts and the railroad has to try
to figure it out and it becomes this
really tense moment you know there's
another uh there's a soldier who i have
quoted in the book who who who recalls
people muttering as he walked down the
street in his town in arkansas
in his where he's wearing his uniform
you know he's he's being uppity he's
he's trying to rise above the station
and uh he eventually moves to st louis
and says i felt safer in the trenches
than i did in arkansas
so this is happening all the time and
the intellectuals are capturing this
desire to really um
how do how do we
how do well dubois said it all we
returned fighting we fought for
democracy there we're going to fight for
democracy here
so you know again we have to take a step
back and think about
how we imagined an african-american say
in 1913
right the average american would would
if you say an african-american they're
wearing overalls they're working on a
farm 90 of african americans live in the
south an overwhelming majority are
farmers of one type or another and so
the idea that in just two years of
american intervention in the war we
would move them from overalls to an
officer's uniform with gleaming metals
confirming their valor
was absolutely incendiary for a lot of
american people and stood as a greater
challenge to getting them again back in
their place and so one of the things we
hear is about how the french have ruined
our negroes right there's a lot of
concern about americans get especially
african-americans suffering from a kind
of contagion from having seen french
democracy from having tasted a life with
fewer social and legal barriers um and
african americans have all these
different ways of communicating
their refusal to return to this funny
you mentioned taste
because i when my book came out i went
on a book tour and i was in baltimore
and i was
on a radio show with a journalist who
had been fortunate enough to interview
the last living world war ii veteran in
baltimore who who happened to be
african-american and he the man was very
old by the time he interviewed him and
all the man talked about was eating
escargot and wine and bread and
everybody was being so nice to him and
just giving him food all the time
and that really was so french right and
that was the experience that i mean the
french people were thrilled that people
were coming to fight for them okay so
there are a couple of things here i i
had a i have a good friend we were
having a conversation he calls about
every three months to ask me how my book
is coming and i'm like look you're
oppressing me at this stage but
anyway we were talking about how the
french had ruined the americans right
the african-americans and one of the
things that african-americans do to
connote and telegraph their awakening
very much like the title of your book is
that they start to throw french words
into
their everyday parlance their everyday
interactions so as to again
change the positionality that they have
so it's you might you wouldn't say hey
how's it going you would say
hello cher
the other thing that african-american
men do and this will drive southerners
bat [ __ ] crazy forgive my language but
that's what it was
that's a medical term yes
um
they would name their their daughters in
particular
with french names and so this friend who
called said oh my god i realize that all
of my great aunts have names like jose
joslin or julie and this was again to
say i have been completely transformed
by my contact with friends and that
transformation is the site of the
conflict in the summer of 19. in the in
the the walking tour that we just gave
in chicago
we began the talk at a victory monument
for and for many decades it was the only
african-american monument to the
african-american soldier in the united
states and it's a very
uh rugged soldier with a rifle and a
bayonet
facing south
and i don't think that was unintentional
but he's looking right at the south
so when we're very familiar with
muhammad ali's stance during the vietnam
war and he says you know a viet cong has
never done anything to me he uses a
different language it's important to
remember that 50 years before that
african americans were saying the exact
same thing
that they were prepared a philip
randolph an african-american newsman
from the period um he earns the dubious
distinction of being the declared by jf
edgar hoover as the most dangerous negro
in america
um he says i'm absolutely prepared to
fight in alabama but not in aras in
france i have no particular battle there
though i value democracy what we see
after the war is that that same vision
comes back we're very familiar with we
returned fighting a short but absolutely
powerful jab penned by w.e.b du bois but
there's another very famous poem
from the period and that is if we must
die by jamaican poet claude mckay and
that last that poem's last lines
if we must die
let us be with our backs pressed to the
wall
fight it dying but fighting back
becomes so
transgressive uh in after world war one
that he is you know of course branded a
communist and and and
almost they consider you know deporting
him etc but in world war ii
churchill returns to that very language
in order to galvanize britain to burn
their loins once more again that's
important
claude mckay uh is is this the anecdote
is important to go into he's a railroad
porter in 1919
and he's traveling with his friends uh
as a lot of uh young black men at the
time he's a railroad porter and they're
going from town to town and every time
the door opens for them to go to their
hotel that night they don't know if
there's a riot
again rumor
and newspapers which were usually a day
late were all the information they had
so they started running to their hotel
cars running to their hotels he started
carrying a gun he was very terrified
and he
he's so nerve wracked by all this that
one day he goes into the bathroom of one
of the railroad cars and scrawls out
this sonnet if
if we must die and he comes back and he
reads it to his friends some of them
start crying
and he
sent it off to this little magazine
which publishes it and then it's
published all over especially among the
african-american press
and it never mentions race the poem
doesn't ever mention race but everybody
knew what it was about and to the point
where
there were white senators in in the
senate saying you know this is seditious
absolutely
i think it was included in hoover's uh
reports about you know sedition
because fighting back was seditious
yes um in fact a threat to democracy at
its core
um in fact let's talk about sedition
because the summer of 1919
is also a period when americans
are afraid of their own shadows
right and that's part of that return to
normalcy
um or that this you know frenetic need
to return to normalcy we
we are worried that having exposed
ourselves to europeans and their
provincial
wars
that
we will in fact bring back
that kind of
of um
instability in the united states so all
of a sudden everyone's a potential
communist right the bolshevik next door
it becomes
a suspicious behavior to read a german
newspaper or speak german in public in
iowa they try to pass a law making
english the official language of the
state when of course it is not the
country has no official language but all
of a sudden we become very worried about
not only bolsheviks within our midst but
how those bolsheviks would get into the
minds of otherwise naive african
americans yeah well that plays a role
throughout 1919 in in
over and over again as these riots erupt
uh
the media coverage is not sometimes is
very very poor and they are flying they
a lot of these rumors that are flying
around end up in print uh and then it
gives that it gives it a solidity that
causes a lot of problems one of them is
you know that there are communists
operating among
the negroes and they're causing problems
there was very little evidence that that
was the case at all and certainly the
leading organization
of that year
was the naacp
which
their position was pretty simple
which was
we're american citizens and we
deserve the same rights as every other
american citizen and we're going to
fight to do that in the courts in how we
when and how we vote and where we live
and what jobs we have and what our
educational opportunities are we're
gonna end and we're and against open
violence against african americans so
we're gonna fight on those fronts uh and
that was considered seditious that was
considered you know to the point where
texas
shut down the naacp and when the naacp
head at the time came to visit austin to
try to unravel this mess who a white man
he was beaten in broad daylight to into
a bloody pulp
by
a mob included that included a judge and
uh other law officials so
it really
um
if you read there was a big report that
hoover uh for um for the attorney
general produced that year
and it has tons of
communist material at the first portion
of it and a lot of anarchist quotes and
and and then it just switches suddenly
very awkwardly to the modern reader into
just publication you know
african-american quotes from you know
quotes from african-american
publications that are
i mean we would read them today and
think well
yeah they should have equal rights i
mean it's very it's very jarring and
weird
yeah but at the time it was
yeah but at the time it was just
um this really contested okay so i well
hence the name red summer right so red
summer means that we're literally seeing
red as james weldon johnson who you'll
tell us about in just a moment suggested
for the blood running through the
streets but it's also because of all the
the red scare the communists were
everywhere and this idea that they would
in particular target african americans
and again infect them with these notions
that that challenged the core of an
american racial hierarchy that worked
let us not forget as well for the north
as it did for the south um
so
well james weldon johnson
tell us i shall bring him up on the
screen
yeah i
i developed as i was researching the
book i developed this uh
uh
here he is man crush for this guy he's
an awesome dude
he uh he's he's one of those people you
start reading about you don't it's
almost like you don't believe it like he
he spoke fluent spanish he was a
diplomat he was a lawyer he wrote tin
pan alley music with his brother he
wrote lyft every voice and sing which is
the africa sort of considered the
african-american national anthem he
wrote poetry he wrote a novel he wrote
uh the amazing essays you know and he's
doing all this
amazing work and
dubois taps him in 1917 and says i want
you to come to the naacp to work with me
and that organization had been founded
after a riot in springfield illinois and
it was
dominated primarily by
uh white do-gooders from in the new york
area
that's mostly leading it was not the an
african-american african-american led
organization at that time
and
james holden johnson says well i i might
do it but i don't know if um it might
hurt my writing
if i do that because i won't have time
and he said just we really need you and
he's so he does join and it completely
hurts his writing he can't produce
anything because he's too busy
1919 that guy is all over the country
giving speeches after speeches after
speech he the
and he's recruiting all over the south
which was a place where they did not
have a lot of members he
you can read his speeches and you think
well this is malcolm x and you read this
another speech and this is martin luther
king and he's tackling all the issues
that later become
uh what the civil rights movement has to
deal with in the 50s and 60s
we have other
people whose voices are very important
on
your left
is
monroe trotter he is a journalist
from boston
and he is very active in for example
denouncing birth of a nation and the
kinds of violence that it's advocating
in the united states and then on the
right is of course w.e.b du bois
uh another sort of renaissance man in
many ways although far more insufferable
than jay
james weldon johnson didn't suffer fools
gladly no he did not um
so
we talked about this briefly what is
meant by the red summer blood bolsheviks
bombings fires um people being set on
fire
rage these are all very worrisome
um daily occurrences for americans and
seem to indicate that the war has
crossed the pond right that the the
warring mood in europe may well have
reached the united states albeit fueled
by different things
it's very important to remember
that race riots did not occur just in
the united states that in fact they had
started in europe as early as 1915. they
begin in my research in european medical
hospitals because what a wonderful i
mean what an obvious place to see
contested terrain when wounded when near
death whose life has greater value the
white soldier or the black soldier do we
segregate our hospitals or not
the british the french the germans all
had stances on this and as a result we
see a lot of fighting and racialized
violence
we also get a lot of violence in
european port cities where both um
colonial soldiers and african-american
soldiers and white soldiers are pouring
in at alarming rates and
you know with a great sense of urgency
so in 1718 we start to get these race
riots namely in western france in
bordeaux in senezak
to a lesser extent in marseille in the
south
we get them immediately after the war in
welsh and british military camps chiefly
in liverpool cardiff but also as far as
glasgow
where allied troops and american troops
are stockpiled and waiting for the ships
that could carry them home with ports
frozen those ships can't go as quickly
as possible with influenza
um striking so many soldiers were very
concerned about putting ten thousand
soldiers on one ship and having so many
die at sea or so many you know get sick
along the way which certainly happened
um
this concern about american contact and
to another extent south african contact
so a lot of white south africans and
white southerners who are in europe
start these riots and in the european
press we get a lot of accounts of these
soldiers saying things are the
representatives saying things like
well you europeans thought you were so
great and incapable of racial strife but
when you have no rules you have people
who don't know their place and hence we
have to get involved and have these
riots so it's very interesting reading
um and then we have all of this fighting
that occurs on the very ships bringing
back these veterans in the case of
canada and its black soldiers they're so
concerned about this um
this fiery mood that they have their
black soldiers
remove their uniforms while at sea and i
just want to say one last thing about
uniforms you know one of the reasons
that soldiers are allowed to and in fact
encouraged to keep their uniforms for 30
to 90 days after returning is so that
that a grateful nation can bestow its
gifts
right so and those thanks could be
anything from food to sex
to booze to words and so when we have
when we require that soldiers take away
or when we're ripping off their uniforms
it's in part to say we owe you no thanks
what did you do to erase the
the contributions by these soldiers
there are multiple root causes i'm going
to move quickly because we want to hear
your questions
it's a fight over labor it's a fight
over housing especially in urban spaces
it's a fight over racial equality and
civil rights whose rights who gets to
define this democracy and of course the
time-honored tradition because it works
so well
interracial sex a universal paranoia
because it also
requires us to think about white women
or just women writ large and their
sexual choices right i mean if she's
with someone who is not you that means
she chose hopefully that someone who is
not you and that alone could be a
contested
moment um so this is just a quick list
and not even a full one of the various
locations where we see race riots in
1919 hawaii mexico trinidad tobago
british honduras jamaica portuguese
africa the list is long
common factors in my research heat and
leisure
contested we started with that migration
and housing crunches veterans returning
to these cities laborers labor union
communists something that um
cameron just touched and of course the
creation of transnational black
alliances the naacp is international but
there are lots of other um marcus garvey
really starts to take off that year
uh um i one thing i would point out you
you mentioned sharecroppers yeah
sharecroppers uh
are the quintessentially downtrodden
class in american
history and certainly
the um
to the point where lenin is writing to
the communist politburo like why can't
we recruit
uh more more people uh in the more black
people in the south to to join our cause
but in 1919
you know they would invariably rip be
ripped off when they would go to weigh
their cotton at the cotton gins but that
year because there was such a high
demand for cotton cotton prices were
through the roof
they were actually doing fairly well
relatively so
you see a lot more sharecropper families
buying land you see a lot more
sharecroppers
buying cars
these are
um
bones of contention these are
flashpoints because here did you see
that black guy driving down the street
in a in a brand new car
when
i begin my book with a small riot in the
middle of a of in not even a town just
as there's a small black church in in
the in a part of georgia are very rural
to this day part of georgia and when the
mob riots they burn the church down they
kill several people and they destroy the
man they're trying to seek cars they
destroy his cars it's a very
important point for them
because cars
then like now are the second largest
expenditure that anyone will make except
that it's a dick
the white mobs move into um the black
belt of chicago and riot and destroy the
place they make a point of destroying
victrolas like taking victrolas out and
smashing them in the street because
those were
el they were expressions of wealth
it's why they burn down churches it's
why they burn down i mean they talk
about um you know bombing caravans where
people would
white people would drive through black
neighborhoods in you know sort of a
string of cars and just throwing bombs
around or throwing oil and then setting
things in place this is a map
of some and here it's very important to
say just some of the places that
witnessed a level of violence that
warranted that ultimately made it onto
the pages of local newspapers right but
it's estimated that between 34 and 37
outright riots occurred in 1919 alone
and these little um these sites do not
account for the daily microaggressions
that are fueled by the same kind of ire
right by the same contest of space i
mean and also just open i mean there are
a lot of lynchings that took place in
the south that
we'll never know about even during the
war itself
um so speaking of lynchings this is a
map
of um lynchings
uh you know it's just in the south but
it's important to remember that they
didn't occur just in the south
um and
and they weren't all african-americans
absolutely not well the majority of us
already were but they weren't all they
were oftentimes jewish uh italian labor
activists they were um hispanic hispanic
uh they were homosexuals sometimes um
there were women which we forget
uh and lynching isn't
the only way that people
are
that it is made clear for a people that
their their lives are in danger right
banishment
um sundown towns et cetera or it's you
know we have to remember that between
1917 and easily 1927
african-americans are on the run for a
different set of reasons
this is a short but by no means complete
list
of uh some of the key race riots that we
get uh in the immediate years after the
war
and so yeah july 27 to august 3rd 1919
this is when chicago is a flame
uh over these race riots
here is just an example of the chicago
defenders front page uh and you know
interestingly they couldn't publish the
paper because they were cut off from
penned into their neighborhoods please
the owner of of the defender has to
drive
uh the paper to a place in indiana where
they eventually publish it
so if you were to look at the newspaper
in the dates that i just showed you
would get a sense that nothing in fact
happened you have to look in the middle
of august to find the retelling of this
rash of riots of course this was
international news not just um chicago
news but this is another
chicago newspaper the broad ax and
african american newspaper
one of the things that i write about in
my work is how the summer of 1919
really changed
the military presence in
african-american communities we when we
have the race riot in omaha
tanks are brought in machine guns are
brought in tanks are the emblem of world
war one tanks are the thing that we
associate with no man's land in northern
france not
downtown omaha
right and so here i find this photo
you know just absolutely
delicious in its potential
what is happening between these two guys
right and then there's the child on the
side who's like this is juicy
he's probably a little kid selling
newspapers
but nonetheless
there's the lunch room which we know
right in the 60s will become a site of
civil rights protest
and
who stands down
who stands down
there uh here you want to talk about
chicago well i mean i think everything
is in chicago well this is
that might be washington but um but it's
important to note that you know the
what after the chicago riot
uh the african-american community
desperately wanted
the militia to come in because they were
besieged and there really was no food or
water getting into medicine medical
supplies provident hospital the leading
african-american hospital there was
overwhelmed and the the nurses and the
staff were exhausted and they needed
people to be to bring supplies in and
and it's 100 degrees yeah and again
remember it's boiling hot uh there are
white gangs moving up and down the
perimeter of the african-american area
and there are black gangs moving within
it looking for white victims and it
becomes this chaotic place where
they just want order restored and when
the militia finally shows up
they
do exactly that they restore order very
quickly they point bayonets at the white
mobs white mobs vanish there's so here
is a truck delivering milk and bread
in chicago
and it has to be with armed guards
but we can't forget
that even if that is a good military
presence right a safeguard in a broader
national
political culture that that
sees african americans as a criminalized
population we forget that these weapons
are not there to keep african-americans
in place but rather to protect them
these become images that afterwards
represent
a harder
or a higher level of violence perhaps
needed to put african-americans where
they belong well and that really like
let's take chicago as a classic example
but it really reshapes
the city of chicago's politics i would
argue today
to today but uh you know you have this
hardening of neighborhoods you know this
is my neighbor this is your neighborhood
there's a
it's balkanized yes it's very and and
that balkanization was already there but
it really hardens there's there's strong
belief
uh that
he was definitely a member of one of the
gangs but that the original richard
daley the mayor of the city of chicago
was actually in the riots participating
which
if anybody knows chicago wouldn't that
wouldn't be too surprising but
and so what are we what are we as
like center your inner
white
midwesterner for a moment or any
american maybe even more so southern
what are we afraid of
this is what we're afraid of
this is what we're afraid of right young
healthy african-american who we've
decided didn't know how to use weapons
before they went to europe and came back
knowing which of course they did
um there they we trained them on other
whites with the intent to kill
and told them that they were doing it
for democracy were very worried that
especially with bolsheviks whispering in
their ears
this could quickly turn against us that
is the anxiety that is being stoked that
is the rumor that is being stoked and so
scenes like this a parade in fact
celebrating the soldiers returning in
chicago you'll note
the famed
um
griffins are they griffins lions i don't
know at the chicago public library
okay this
could take over the south
and so a very firm hand is needed these
kinds of posters meant to encourage
african-american enlistment during the
war african-americans pointing their
bayonets at white people who are afraid
this is exactly what we have to erase in
the black memory we should we should go
to questions but i want to re so
um
i'm going to read a little quote from
chester franklin who was an editor at
the
call in kansas city at the time and he
wrote um
he he wrote an article called the new
negro in capital letters and he wrote in
that article in that essay we believe
that self-preservation is the first law
of nature
oh wait no this was later then he wrote
that the new negro the time of cringing
is over
and that really sums up the red summer
like that really captures
his his his uh the message of
african-american leaders in the press
over and over again but he um but i want
to point out one other
thing
okay so there's a there was a journalist
a black journalist named roy otley and
he writes
a memoir and he includes a portion of
covering the red summer and he was in
chicago
and he names he he discusses a
an african-american
veteran who just come back from france
he doesn't name him but he writes about
him and the man is
on a trolley car and suddenly he doesn't
know about what's happening and suddenly
a mob that comes up and attack starts
attacking him and and trolley cars moved
on electrical lines
so what you all you had to do was pull
the cord off and it was dead so that's
what they do he has to run out and he's
running suddenly a man who was coming
home from work he worked at a factory
he's running for his life he loses his
coat he's terrified and the crowd is
screaming
get the n-word you know get the n-word
to chasing him
and he finally escapes
when he sees kaminsky park on the south
side of the baseball stadium he knows
he's made it to the safe area and he
says
the injustice of the whole thing
overwhelmed me and my feelings ran riot
had the 10 months i spent in france been
all in vain
what had i done to deserve such
treatment i lay there trying to imagine
how the innocent victim of a southern
mob must feel must the negro always
suffer because of his skin
there's an n-word let's get him those
words kept bringing in my ears
and he later sees a white man in his
neighborhood
and he says my first impulse was to jump
him and beat him up
because that's what had been he was so
angry about what had happened
and again this is the guy who was just
fighting
to make the world safer democracy
and
that's well it's you know it's a it's a
fight that continues
it begins it's amplified in 1919 but by
no means ends in 1919. all racial
problems ended at that point of course
it's all over
um so with that on that fine note uh
we'd love to open up the floor to your
questions
um and
we're happy to stay yeah you are
afterward anybody wants to ask us
anything
but any questions would be great
so we can't see you very well because of
the light but yeah so camille has them
welcome if you are able to come down to
either mike or i'm happy to come to you
as well
all right coming to you michael
thank you for this great piece of
history i've got two questions to ask
but i'm only going to ask one not to be
selfish and i'm trying to figure out
which one i want to ask
you mentioned j edgar hoover fbi and how
our organizations were scrutinized
and really demonized then that's a
hundred years ago
recently maybe a year or two ago the fbi
put out a report about it was either
black
extremist
something black identity politics or
something like that so
in your as a historian do you
think that the black community is still
being
looked at that way by our government
are you asking me
both of you okay either
um
well you know sometimes you have to
develop a sense of humor when you
work on war and genocide as i do
um
and so sometimes when i'm looking at the
surveillance records and they're not
just in the united states the french the
british the canadians the jamaicans they
are all very very concerned about the
movement of ideas and the movement of
black bodies that incorporate these
ideas right so there's this whole sort
of um
set of paperwork and new language that
develops in 19 during the war and even
more so afterwards and so sometimes i
feel like the best thing that ever
happened to african-american newspapers
and black intellectuals was j edgar
hoover because he is so obsessed that he
keeps everything you know that he hears
his voice historians anyways yes yes um
you know his agents are constantly
collecting papers and some that we would
not have anymore but for their presence
in these surveillance records so i think
you know i tell my students that we
might well revere
uh muhammad ali
and malcolm x and romanticize you know
who we think these men were but neither
of them could get on a plane today
if they were alive because they would be
considered muslim radicals right so i
think that there is
still a concern and an anxiety about
what black people think
and a need
to
explain it away to blame you know to
have a xenophobic kind of concern about
them
and and at the end of the day like
refuse to believe that they are
african-americans own critiques about
how democracy fails them in their daily
lives so i don't i don't think that i
mean i hope that answers your question
i don't think it's it's stopped or will
anytime soon i would point out also a
lot of this critique in
a lot of these reports that i read early
on the fbi was
not official but they were starting to
create this sort of
group under under uh mitchell palmer
but
they're really bad like they're really
they're assessments of of what's really
happening in the streets of chicago
during the riot are way off and
um
you know they're making it they're a lot
of the rumors that were spread that you
know african americans had broken into
the armory and were stealing 10 000 guns
and whites were murdering hundreds of
people and dumping them into this creek
behind the slaughter house
they put that in their reports and those
are not that never happened
neither of those things happened so
there's a lot of bad uh assessment
that's just
that that wasn't some great surveillance
work right sometimes it's blatant job
protection yeah
i'm serious i'm serious especially in
the case of france like because they're
you know they're like well i have to
have a purpose i spent the war focusing
on germans and now i have to take what
skills i have and use them to demonize a
different set of people
um so
our next question comes from the center
um you had a map up earlier and it
denoted the various different parts of
the south where all of these um riots
were taking place
um
so
uh i want to make sure i'm clear was
there any one definitive incident
in all of those locations that triggered
it or was it just the overall climate
that you were talking about from 1919
was there just one incident in each one
of those places excellent question um so
i had to speed through it when i listed
you know different factors and this is
really where cam's gonna have this is
his wheelhouse um
there are just each place has a
different kind of manifestation of its
anxiety if you will in the case of port
cities
i think we would agree that soldiers and
sailors play a particular role in the
case of chicago maybe omaha work plays a
different role um as a stimulant right
or as a a catalyst um
when in doubt always say some white girl
got some attention um because that one
never fails so but anyway
i mean there's
i start my book in a this small town in
georgia but of course there were
incidents before that
but
that incident gathers the gains the
attention of the naacp in new york then
the naacp has a has a giant forum on
trying to push for federal lynching
legislation in new york then charleston
there's a big riot in charleston caused
by sailors and then it starts to really
gain steam and there are incidents um
we have a pointer oh my god here you go
look at this green button he's super
fancy
is this gonna work okay so wow look at
me um
charleston is really the first major
urban riot and ironically
it's actually the best handled because
the navy the naval office the commander
and the mayor of the city
immediately worked together to shut it
down
because the african-american community
was so important and vital to that city
that even in the steep south
where
the civil war began
they they shut it down but uh un
unfortunately that's not repeated so
then you have uh incidents start to pop
up all over uh
some of knoxville is a terrible one
bisbee arizona is very interesting where
uh buffalo soldiers are brought to a
fourth of july parade and
uh it becomes a shootout after they when
they go out drinking and uh white men
don't like where you know that they're
coming into their bars
but really when you start to have
washington d.c
in in mid-july
and then chicago a week after
that's when everyone in the country is
saying
what what the hell is going on with our
country and washington is is really
important internationally
because you have you know there i found
german and japanese
newspaper articles where they're saying
what is this is this is the leading
democracy in in the united states what i
mean in the world what's happening this
country is having a riot right it is
right outside of the white house
and i found a german paper that actually
said
um
this is insane what's happening over
there and someday
they might even have a black president
it's horrific so um anyways but it just
starts roiling the entire country and as
as we point out at the beginning
um you know newspaper after newspaper
headline banner headlines
every day
panicked everyone
so that's an important place to add two
more things here and that is that as the
riots move westward
i see an uptick in the kind of violence
that we see as well and elaine arkansas
is the worst it's written in it's
increasingly referred to as
you know a pogrom
right the kind of violence we're seeing
with jews in in southern russia um and
ukraine yeah that happens in september
in elaine arc oh geez no i did it
too much tech there we go all right
i fixed it um
yeah elaine arkansas is really basically
um
a massacre yes i don't think but plainly
um so and part of the reason why there's
that amplification is because oh my god
you heard what happened in dc oh so when
it and when a little thing happens in
chicago it's like everybody has to get
involved and then as we you know with
each
each
race riot means a greater response to it
and more people in the streets and there
are accounts of you know
people especially here women
fighting each other off with pots and
pans
right and what do i tell my students
like this not only describes a real
frenzied kind of violence on the street
but it means that like grandma's taken
to the street
and
we know that you know when grandma gets
involved it's about to get messy
right so um so yeah it's a real and
again this doesn't even
capture
the full extent of that summer
so um i hope that answered your question
thank you we'll take our next question
on the right
the the map doesn't show anything
happening in missouri or kansas is that
because nothing happened or because it
was just very
low-key
i think it's safe to say there was
probably tension here but there were not
massive race riots kansas city has had a
very vocal and an interesting
african-american
press
which i
used for my book but they were not
they did not have an incident like you
had in omaha
why
pure luck
but also by the end of like by 1919
certainly by the fall of 1919
we start to realize that these riots are
messy they're easy fodder for our
enemies so the europeans who barely
could suffer wilson to begin with were
like well well well if it isn't mr
democracy kind of with him on that one
but yeah um
right can't even handle his own mess
and um so that's not good and then
secondly
uh this idea that um we need to shut
them down quickly and if that means
bringing in the military we will if it
means increasing our police force we
will because it's we can't return to
business um so
we get if we look only for these little
fabulous orange explosions then we miss
all the other ways of like women
stabbing each other on sidewalks right
and people's homes being bombed these
small scale
exercises of violence that are again
fueled by the same kinds of commitments
and i'll i'll come back here and i'll
give a four-hour lecture about why
woodrow wilson is a terrible president
if you want but just in just two
sentences i mean he well more than two
but he was throughout this mess as this
rolled across the country
he's focused on the league of nations
and this is embarrassing
and but you have african-american
leaders and others
writing him pleading with him you gotta
say something here you gotta interject
and i only found one speech where he
makes a passing reference to these
troubles are messy and we really
shouldn't do that
you know
while he's on the stump for the league
of nations but he would not
take any serious action
yes our next question is it comes from
the back okay
i was also really interested in this
map and also the list of riots what what
i'm interested in is really the language
of it um when i hear the word riot you
know it's it's not clear kind of who the
good guys and bad guys are but i was
wondering like the examples you give it
kind of sounds more like white terrorism
yeah as opposed to you know like a black
riot or any any group um i was just kind
of which was language used at the time
by the way
um i was you know just kind of wondering
like what what really was the nature of
all those like were there bad people on
both sides or is this really just you
know like a terrorism and then like a
defense or an uprising kind of thing i i
the overwhelming amount of of violence
that summer that was anti-black violence
star initiated
there were many instances where blacks
fought back and and fought
there were no instances that i can think
of where
blacks initiated the violence
i think people tend to be and then um
so i mean people tend to think of uh
they are different and you you bring up
a good point but i think people get hung
up on the terminology a lot of like
well you know it
this is
i was thinking about this as i flew in
here actually because this is something
that's been bugging me so i'm gonna
fire off a little bit about it but but
people want to see
uh history often as it's hitler versus
gandhi right and that's not the
everybody involved in all of these
things was a human being and if you're a
human being and people are marching down
your street breaking windows
you might pick up a brick
and
there were people who were in chicago
who fought back or there were there were
black gangs because you know why
three blocks over there were white gangs
and if you're you're you know and so
when all the trouble started they
started causing they started causing
violence too and if you were on the
wrong side of that color line you were
you were gonna get it
but at the same time elaine arkansas was
as i said a massacre and the lynching in
aliceville uh mississippi was
horrific
um you know i would say that it's even
more specific than i think we miss a lot
when we look for like a we use a white
black binary
because in the case of east st louis
which happens a little bit earlier but
also we see it in chicago
white women
are
just as involved and they're just as
violent and they're just as engaged in
making their leaving their stamp in this
in this white black battle and so if we
look at these riots through the lens of
gender my students get very
uncomfortable so that's not ladylike i
thought these were these girls were in
jazz clubs getting lit right um but no
they are involved women are very very
powerful in the clan
which gets its resurgence at this time
and other white supremacist
organizations i mean the clan is not
even the worst really um it just isn't
my favorite is the national association
for the advancement of white people
which was a real thing uh it comes later
but it's a real thing
so women
you know children are involved in this
fighting older people are involved in
this fighting it's a it's a neighborhood
brawl
oftentimes certainly in chicago and if
you're riding in if you're gathering a
mob in in vicksburg mississippi it's
going to be a very different white mob
than what you're going to gather in
chicago so in my book i mentioned this
but there were
they did a really precise drill down
investigation of what happened in
chicago unlike a lot of these other
places
and so you really get to see
so
you know these gangs would include um
a jewish kid an irish kid a german kid
and they could all
then become
white correct and it was their way to
immigrants sometimes it's soldiers
sometimes you know so it's not just one
factor
and that's part of what makes these
battles so complicated and at the same
time so telling
so but the vast majority anti-black
initiated yeah
this will be our second to last question
okay
you mentioned
arkansas and mississippi i think and
some terrible things happened i really
want to know what those things were what
happened in arkansas what happened in
mississippi
well um arkansas was um you know i was
talking about sharecroppers and how they
did relatively well that year so the
price of cotton was through the roof
so a lot of
um
a lot of sharecroppers in various parts
of the south started to try to organize
to create a collective where they would
go to the cotton gins and say this is
our price
so they started to have meetings
and they're holding a meeting in hoops
spur arkansas which isn't even a real
town
at a little building there and white
police show up and a shooting starts
and
some white officers are killed
well that's
that that sets off a a
pot white posses roaming the county
killing people
for for days they then rounded up a
bunch of um
uh african-american sharecroppers uh
beat them bloody and had them confess to
a grand conspiracy
uh that was never really very defined
that they were going to be that there
was a plot to kill every white person in
the county
that was challenged by the naacp and
others
in a very very long legal suit that
eventually led to the supreme court and
those men
were who were on death row after trials
that lasted literally minutes
uh were all exonerated and let go
who here has had the great pleasure of
raising a teenager
okay
i'm in the trenches
so there's nothing more cocky than a
teenager who gets their first paycheck
right because now they think you don't
have the same power over them because
they don't need your wallet
and whether you like it or not it
changes how you respond to that said
teenager
and so it's a useful way that i have my
students who are themselves teenagers
think about how worrisome this would
have been this is when african americans
are not allowed to challenge a white
person in court never mind in court in
public and so the fact that they were
trying to gain control over the value of
their labor how bolshevik
[Music]
right by saying not only has cotton gone
up but we know that it can't continue to
go up because we no longer need all this
cotton for uniforms and tents and and
you know cotton etc i mean for bandages
etc so we want to make money now
and what we start to see especially in
these small rural areas i mean the land
ownership is real and it's huge but it's
not so gigantic that it would have
destabilized the southern economy but it
doesn't take a lot to make it seem like
it's an idea that might catch on so i'm
sorry one second
so
in elaine what we get are not just these
african americans who try to organize as
cotton farmers but they also
have money and having access to cash is
very hard in the southern economy at
this time
and
we see
that there is a success among african
americans in the forms of buildings so
when you build your church when you add
an attachment to your home when you get
that other car and what we get with just
as much ferocity uh after world war one
is an urge to erase
right burn to the ground these tropes of
success modernity again squeezing back
into your place and so i tell my
students
pick a date and pick an african-american
newspaper and there is a church going up
in flames why because after you build
your own house you have money left over
to give to the preacher to build a
church
so we need that church to go and why the
church because it's where meetings were
held and oftentimes in small towns it's
where the guns were stashed so again in
63 64 birmingham and other locations
where we're attacking black churches is
because they had already been sites of
protest for over 50 years
right it's the place where after i just
wanted to i didn't want to miss your
question regarding mississippi
um so i won't go into the long story but
it's horrific uh but uh a man was
it's important and i focus on i give a
full chapter to it because there are
many lynchings that take place that year
but that lynching was particularly
horrific all lynchings are horrific of
course but
a man was accused of
sexually assaulting a white woman
i don't know if you've ever heard of
that that's a constant accusation that
they would make right
we don't we'll never know if it was true
or not because
he ran away because they were going to
kill him posse found him shot him
fatally
but then they brought a doctor in kept
him alive for 24 hours
so that they could lynch him and let
everyone know to come to the party
and that was
not very common among their little but i
mean it's unique that it was like this
was published in the newspaper like
headlines like not there was a lynching
yesterday there will be a lynching
tomorrow come to the lynching uh to the
point where the naacp
uh
sent emergency telegrams to the governor
of mississippi saying you you have to
stop this this is an extrajudicial
killing this is this man hasn't even
been accused of a crime
and uh the governor's response was well
if you're going to rape a white woman
what are you going to do
forgetting the fact that the man
there was no trial let alone there
wasn't even an accusation that was
formally made in court that and and they
proceeded to then
shoot him to bits and
sold pieces of his body there were
postcards made of the event um people
gave speeches as we heard from the
beginning so it was really sort of this
horrific public display
our last questions on the right
um i mean i don't mind taking both
it's up to you
i mean we will end with this question
and then both sage and cameron will be
available in the lobby
thank you for coming
dr matthau
how do you see the cultural climate of
the red summer impacting suffrage of
african-american women
that's a great yes could you replete
your question for the audience please
and then i'll stall
now just kidding
how do you see the cultural climate of
red summer impacting suffrage of
african-american women super
um thank you for that i
i think that it's important for us to
remember that african-american women and
the one who comes immediately to mind as
ida b wells right were also journalists
they were also sounding the alarm in
fact wells was at the forefront in terms
of warning
african americans and the country at
large about lynching and the ways in
which we legitimized it or tried to by
saying that these were you know
necessary responses because of acts of
sexual aggression against white women
and so
african-american women
are
in during the war lynched oftentimes for
defending their their husbands um
there's a great
great uh
newspaper piece from i believe it's
atlanta where on the one hand a woman
whose name i'm forgetting right now 18
years old is lynched violently
and it's on the same day
that we're praising an african-american
soldier named henry johnson for having
fought off these a german trench attack
and so again this idea that you could
be perfectly safe against
the worst army at the time right the
image of the worst most violent
transgressive army but not safe in your
home trying to defend your own husband
and so i think that african-american
women who had already been very much
involved in the black church who had
already understood the import of
suffrage
it's not it's not like they they come
round at the end to the idea that women
need a voice in the polity they too had
been fighting for that voice they too
had been building organizations and
networks and alliances that allowed them
to articulate their their political
concerns um african-american women are
very involved in prohibition
right i mean du bois for one thing he's
a teetotaler and he's he's uh he's and
he could have used the drink once in a
while he was like who that is
right
like i'm i'm i'm absolutely a
hypocritical meat-eater if there's no
bone i'm all in there but if there's a
bone i'm like ah um
so
uh but anyway so there were all of these
other ways that black women had been
rallying for the lives of their their
loved ones and understanding that the
ballot box is as important as space
there's a an author i enjoy greatly um
david ceselski and he writes about a
chap named abraham
uh
or galloway
and who is this just fabulous
character but anyway abraham galloway
talks about how he learned about civil
rights from his black grandmother who as
a child would march him down to the
voting booth
in charleston
and she would pack a gun in her purse to
let him know that you need to fight
for your right to protect your rights
and the the right to vote is an
important pillar of reconstruction
ideology for african americans but it
works hand in hand
with
the gun with education with the church
and so armed resistance is always talked
about with african americans as
um a kind of point to which
a point where african americans get
angry in the 60s and just start burning
[ __ ] down right and but in actuality why
we have to have so much discussion about
non-violence as a legitimate
option uh it's because
armed resistance was a perfectly viable
option
and in world in 1919 we see this with
these veterans coming back and making a
claim for themselves as citizen soldiers
who are prepared to defend not only
their own immediate lives but also those
of their communities so in chicago in
dc in omaha we get we get these reports
reports sometimes exaggerated but
oftentimes true of african-american
soldiers setting up a perimeter on the
roofs of buildings to defend their
communities no differently than they
would have needed to do in verdun
or any of the other points along the
western front and um
sort of to your point uh
there was this
so that we've talked a lot about a lot
of horrific things that have happened
but the ultimate answer was
african-americans weren't going to be
stuffed back into that space
in this in in the rural south
in in in the certainly not in the cities
of chicago and washington it didn't work
and
for men and women
african-american men and women that
things had forever changed and so right
after here comes the harlem renaissance
which women participated in uh and you
just see this
they're not going back into their
station they're not going back
i'll add one last thing and then really
i'll be done um
and that is that we forget that
african-american women were the ones who
wrote in to african-american newspapers
uh these columns so when you look at at
black newspapers they're always like
local news right and and so they are the
ones who are reporting what they're
seeing from the window they are the ones
saying i lost my good pan against the
head of this kid who thought he could
come and burn my house right um so it is
their voices that we see through these
newspapers and through organizations
even if ken surprise they're overlooked
as women right um as the intellectual
and organizational muscle um in in
various post-war organizations but they
could not have worked i mean not
madam cj walker
uses much of her fortune to support
precisely the kind of work including
suffrage that you asked about
so thank you again for being here with
us this evening
you're watching american history tv